you're an aspiring architect prepare for
war
architecture school is no easy feat you
will lose sleep your ego will be
destroyed and your social life say
goodbye to that these will be the best
and worst five years of your life let me
explain
you and thousands of other students will
walk onto this metaphorical battleground
and only a handful of you will return
with that covenant piece of paper you'll
spend months creating your first design
only to realize that you should have
been forging a shield to protect you
from what's about to come your first
presentation your first pin up might
actually just be your last those first
five minutes of fame feel like an
eternity not for the right reasons every
single fault every single flaw in your
design every single minor imperfection
will feel like a dagger to your soul
unfortunately this is the truth and the
harsh reality of presentation and pin
day okay maybe i'm over exaggerating
just a little bit however architecture
is extremely hard and it is not the
easiest subject to study at university
your first day could be absolutely
anything most people would expect to go
into architecture school and start
drawing buildings on their first day
well for example my first day at
university instead of drawing buildings
we actually started drawing live nude
models and they were all posing in the
most inappropriate and uncomfortable
positions so trust me it was
uncomfortable and awkward as it was not
a pleasant experience however it gave us
an incredibly good talking point between
all the peers that we never really knew
before so basically the point of the
first day of architecture is to get
everybody out of their comfort zones
with an extremely unique icebreaker
exercise that every single year group is
completely different when you finally
get to design something and you finally
get to present on that pinup board bring
that shield i'm being serious for the
next five years of university degree
you're gonna need that shield to protect
yourself and to protect your ego because
it's gonna get torn down every single
time you present it doesn't matter how
good you are the purpose of the
presentation is to genuinely expose you
to the rough reality of the real world
clients councils all sorts of people in
the industry slowly tearing down your
design and saying it isn't feasible it
isn't possible or how can we make this
work in a completely different way so
even though that experience was
extremely traumatic for all people
studying architecture at the end of the
day i'm still very truly grateful for
that experience because it taught me the
harsh realities of what's about to come
your undergraduate degree is three years
long at least it is in australia it is a
mix of history theory technical drawing
and practical design you'll need to
spend hundreds and hundreds of hours
studying each one of these topics just
to pass and you need to spend thousands
of hours to be able to get a good grade
if you're thinking you're going to get
that ideal college experience where
you're going to be able to go out party
all night long and just do whatever you
absolutely want well i'm sorry to inform
you architecture is not the subject that
you're going to be able to do that with
yes there is going to be times when you
can do that but most of the time your
day will be 12 hours of studying 10
hours of working 2 hours of thinking
what the hell am i doing with my life
and no hours sleeping but because you're
not sleeping you're most likely spending
all your time on campus with a whole
bunch of people very similar to you
which means you're going to be spending
all this time with people developing
some of the strongest and longest
lasting relationships of your life to
this day i'm still incredibly good
friends with everybody that i went to
university with that made it through to
the end so it is truly an experience
that you will cherish for your entire
life you will be taught how to design an
architecture school so if you don't know
the actual principles of fundamental
design that's okay you will be taught it
however what you won't be taught is 3d
modeling and 3d design so you're going
to have to go out on your own time spend
your own money figure out how you can
actually design something in a 3d
software package so for example if
you're learning archicad you need to
learn all of that on your own the
university most likely won't teach you
anything of the fundamental basics so
you have to go out and invest your own
time and energy into the 3d software the
3d rendering and you're going to have to
learn it extremely fast what you'll
usually see is architecture school is
filled with nice 3d models now most of
the time most lecturers during the very
early years of your degree will make you
make these models by hand you'll be
usually using some sort of soft wood
material plastics or anything in between
sometimes towards the end of your degree
they will let you 3d print a model just
to speed up the efficiency and get those
ideas across however most of the time
you will have to make something by hand
to just genuinely teach you the art and
value of model making and how much it
can add value to your overall design
those three years will go by incredibly
quickly mainly because you're extremely
sleep deprived and have no perception of
time anymore but more so for the fact
that if this is something that you truly
enjoy you will genuinely just enjoy
those three years through university and
you won't really be thinking about the
tough times that you've gone through in
australia however those three years as
an undergraduate degree you'll feel all
great you'll go to your graduation
ceremony you'll throw your hat up in the
air but unfortunately that degree means
absolutely nothing you're going to need
to spend a little bit more time at
university and a little bit more time in
the real world before you can call
yourself an architect so i do suggest
that you go straight into your master's
degree which is another two years after
your undergraduate degree for a
magnitude of reasons first of all you're
carrying through all those friendships
that you've built over the last three
years and second of all you're not
tempted to just go into the workforce
and keep working for that larger amount
of money up front but that less amount
of money in the long run during these
two years i call this practical
architecture and something that's
related a little bit more back to the
real world you'll be spending two years
on one project you'll be writing a
thesis you'll be not sleeping like
always and you will learn all the
practical skills that you need to be a
hirable grad when you finish your
master's degree the first year of your
master's is a little less intense it's
usually the time that you actually
understand what's going on you figure
out the practicalities of design and you
get your workflow streamlined relatively
well so you still might not be getting
enough sleep you'll still be spending
most of your time at university but
overall you will understand the
fundamental basics of the last three
years the final year of your master's
degree is generally a thesis project
which means you have to investigate and
explore a project in great great detail
now every single university is different
every single campus is different but
overall you will be focusing all of your
energy and all of your attention on this
one project which is really good because
this is very similar to how the real
world and real practices work you're
often working on one project for a
prolonged period of time you're not
doing tens of thousands of little
projects over the course of six months
so this will give you a really good
indication of what it's like to work on
one big project for a very long and
extended period of time now even when
you finish your master's degree you're
still going to need that shield so don't
go out and throw that shield away the
rest of your career is still going to be
bombarded with critics and people who
don't like your design so if you're not
used to your ego being bruised a little
bit you're definitely going to need to
keep that shield for a very long time to
come hopefully you'll finish off that
degree get a really good grade throw
your hat up in the air for the second
time but you still won't be able to call
yourself an architect in australia you
need to work for a minimum two years
full time which is equivalent to 3 300
hours of logbook experience broken down
into a number of different categories
you will need to sit a multiple choice
exam and you will need to sit an
interview exam but overall the process
from start to finish from becoming an
architect is seven years at an absolute
minimum unfortunately the reality in
australia is it takes architects an
average of seven years after they
graduate university to become a
registered architect which means on
average it takes australians 12 years to
become registered architects for me
personally it took seven and a half
years for some other people it might
take 20 years it all depends on you it
depends how much you want to work how
much effort you want to put into it and
seven years is the minimum so make sure
you keep that in mind the truth about
architecture is architecture is
incredibly hard there is almost a 95
dropout rate from day one to the day you
graduate your master's degree everybody
on campus thinks you're the crazy guys
on the campus because you're always
walking around like a zombie you're
always sitting in front of your computer
modeling designing rendering you're
going to be up to all hours of the night
just doing project after project it is a
grueling experience but it is an
extremely rewarding time in your life
you will develop some of the best
friendships here you will develop some
of the best memories and it is overall
worth it in my personal opinion and
that's it for me today guys thank you so
much for watching i hope you enjoyed the
video if you did make sure you smash
that like button hit the subscribe
button and like always i'll see you next
monday